-Someone that I am a fan o
and I'm going to guess,
based on his presence in the
film, you're also a fan of
is Action Bronson, who fully
steals a scene that he's in.
How is working with him?
And was that someone,
again, that you had
in mind since the beginning?
-He was one of those guys
that just came in
and just crushed the audition.
He was just so funny.
And we just had to have him.
And he was -- He's a blast
He's just a really fun guy
to have on set.
And he's definitely an
interesting character,
to say the least.
-Yeah. It was funny -- the las
time we had him on the show,
he was talking about how
he was in "The Irishman,"
which I kind of
couldn't believe.
And he was really good
in that, too.
I'm like, "Wow, Action Bronson
two for two
right out of the gate."
-Yeah. "The Irishman" and
"The King of Staten Island
in the same year
is pretty incredible.
-Exactly.
-Also, couldn't care less.
Like, just, like, walked in,
just crushes it.
It's ridiculous.
-Just rolls out right after.
-Yeah.
I will say Action Bronson --
always been
a great guest on our show,
and we're never quite sure
he's going to show up
till the last minute.
And he's never let us down
-Same on our set.
We had no idea if
he was ever gonna come,
and he showed up and just
knocked it out of the park
And we're very grateful
for that.
-It's incredible
the patience you will have
with people who deliver.
-Yeah.
-You play an aspiring
tattoo artist in the film.
You obviously have tattoos
of your own.
Is this something -- Have yo
ever given one in real life?
-I've given a couple to
my friends, like,
little, tiny tattoos
with like, words and stuff
but nothing too crazy, because I
have a shaky hand, I was told.
-Yeah.
-So it's not really great
for tattooing.
-Yeah. It would seem like
that's, like, the way they -
It would be like, if you'r
afraid of the water,
they'd probably say, you know,
"Swimming's not for you."
There is a scene
where you work in a restaurant
and people fight for tips, like,
physically fight for tips.
Is this something you pulled
from your own life?
-When I used to work at
my uncle's Italian restaurant,
if there was ever, like,
a beef with another co-worker --
It wouldn't be for tips,
but if there was ever a beef
he thought it would be
a great idea to have
Hulk hands and boxing gloves
after work,
where you and your co-worker
can duke it out.
And, you know, whoever win
wins the argument.
And I got into one of thos
fights and I got annihilated
so I just thought it would b
funny to throw in the movie.
-Is it -- It was --
in real life,
did you do it the same way
Did you do it in the center of
the restaurant after hours
-Yeah. They just cleared
everything out of the way
and they were like,
"Alright, Pete, you're up.
I hope it was
worth that argument
you had earlier at 9:00 a.m.
That's the thing is, like,
when you have like
a 12-hour work day,
something you have at night,
you're like, "I don't even
care anymore.
I don't want to get
my ass kicked."
-Yeah. Well, that's like -
I would say, like --
At "SNL," my theory was, if yo
were upset about something
don't bring it up at the party
See if you're still mad
by Monday.
And the reality is, like,
time makes everything
seem petty, which is helpful
-Right. Yeah.
-Do you -- You guys did three,
I guess,
social-distancing shows.
You managed to do a song
with Adam Sandler
about being stuck at home,
which was fantastic.
I mean, certainly
a hero of mine.
How did that come about?
-I'm pretty tight with
"The Sand Man,"
which is the coolest thing
I think, I ever get to say
He is just such a cool,
nice guy.
I can't explain how wonderfu
of a person he is.
And I just reached out
and texted him and was like,
"Hey, is there any shot
you would ever
want to do a song together?"
And he was like,
"Hell yeah, buddy."
And it was awesome.
And we just sent each othe
notes and stuff back and forth
And he came up with
that great verse.
And it just fell together.
I was really thrilled.
-He is -- It is one of the -
I think, you know,
when people ask you,
"Who are the nicest people
you've met that are
celebrities?",
it's really fun to be able t
tell them that Adam Sandle
is truly one of the nicest
human beings they can meet
People are very happy
to hear that,
because I think they would b
heartbroken if he was a bad guy,
and it is the opposite.
-Oh, yeah.
Yeah, he's definitely the best
Just, like,
very caring and sweet
and actually not full of crap,
which is very rare to find
-Back when you guys were doing
the in-studio shows last season,
did you have
a personal favorite?
Was there a highlight
for you last year?
-My favorite was
the Mulaney show,
when we got to do another
one of those
bodega-bathroom-type things.
And we had just -- I just love
those musical numbers.
I think it's really fun to hav
like a 12-minute sketch
that's just ridiculous.
And it's always fun
to work with Mulaney.
I think he's
the greatest, as well.
-It's also very fun that you are
such an essential cog
to this trilogy of musicals now.
Like, really, without
your character's bad decisions
we'd never hear
any of these songs.
-Right. It's all up to me.
-Buddy, congrats again
on the movie.
It's fantastic.
Thank you so much
for being here.
It's always nice to see you.
Hopefully, next time,
it'll be in person.
-Thanks for having me, Seth.
I appreciate it.
Hope to see you soon.
-Alright.
Say hello to your mother for me.
-Alright, I will.